when you hear about jihadist terrorism
what's the first thing that comes to
mind probably the attack on the World
Trade Center in New York in 2001 maybe
the B clan in Paris Isis fighting
savagely in Syria or Iraq bah Haram in
Nigeria in other words we generally
place jihadism in the Middle East Africa
or Europe but what if I were to tell you
that it's high time to put South America
on the map haven't you noticed that this
vast region is almost always overlooked
whenever this subject is discussed okay
that's normal jihadist activity has not
been as intense there as in other areas
but what if I were to tell you that this
could change what if I told you that
there is one Latin American country
where jihadism already has a strong
presence take a look Caribbean jihadists
why Trinidad and Tobago has become the
capital of De in the west Jesus Christ
is personified as a white man with blue
eyes and people hate white supremacy
says an Imam under anonymity indeed it's
not Argentina nor Colombia nor Mexico no
no this time we're going to talk about a
small Caribbean nation that many
analysts rate as the largest nest of
jihadists in the west I'm talking about
Trinidad and Tobago Trinidad and Tobago
a nation made up of two main islands off
the coast of Venezuela sits today in the
crosshairs of international
counterterrorism intelligence this small
country used to stand out above all for
being a major exporter of oil and
natural gas which is why they have
dedicated themselves almost exclusively
to this since their independence these
days however it's no longer known so
much for that but for jihadism and for
having one of the highest homicide rates
in the Americas which is saying
something in fact Trinidad and Tobago
has the second highest homicide rate in
the Americas behind only Jamaica so
that's saying a lot and of course at
this point I'm sure many of you are
wondering how on Earth did Trinidad and
Tobago become the Western epicenter for
jihadism when did this drift towards
Islamic fundamentalism begin is Trinidad
and Tobago just the beginning of a
jihadist wave in South America today
visual politic viewers we're going to
answer these questions and many more
stay
tuned the jihadist
[Music]
Genesis as many of you can imagine
Trinidad and Tobago did not Escape the
Fate of the European colonial empires it
was also under their control starting in
1592 with the first Spanish settlements
both Islands passed through French hands
and finally ended up under British
control becoming a major cotton and
sugar producing colony and so it
remained until almost 400 years later
when in 1962 Trinidad and Tobago gained
its independence from the United Kingdom
and as I'm sure many of you are already
thinking it didn't take long for new
problems to appear for this fledgling
country as soon as Trinidad and Tobago
gained its independence its economy
began to collapse due to the reduction
in international demand for its main
export products such as cocoa sugar and
citrus fruits the unemployment rate soon
reached 15% % by the end of the 1960s
and mass protests in the streets became
common place however between 1973 and
1981 due to the Saudi Oil Embargo
against the West this small Caribbean
Nation benefited from the rising price
in the oil barrel the result an oil boom
that allowed it to improve the living
conditions of its citizens nevertheless
when things with the Arabs Got Back On
Track and that boom ended in the early
1980s the level of public spending the
country had taken on suddenly became an
unsustainable burden and given the
differ between imports and exports was a
very similar story instead of saving
anything Trinidad and Tobago were
spending all the money it generated from
hydrocarbons and so when oil and gas
prices fell the country's economy went
into recession and by 1989 the society
was in a desperate situation
unemployment at around 22% and youth
unemployment at 43% to make matters
worse the government had to cut the
subsidies it had created during the good
times mass protests were inevitable and
social unrest was more evident than
ever the country was almost at its limit
and in the end in 1990 something
happened that typically happens in young
countries with weak institutions a catar
took place but it was not another
typical catar carried out by the
military nothing of the sort this
particular cudar was carried out by none
other than a radical islamist group the
jamat AL muslimin that's what I said and
in the middle of South America this
group founded in 1982 by this man you
see on screen Yasin Abu bakir a former
police officer who converted to Islam
attempted a katar in July 1990 Abu bakir
already had problems with the central
government when he occupied land that
had been granted to the confraternity of
Islamic missionaries of the Caribbean
and South America in fact in 1985 he was
arrested for not complying with a Court
ruling ordering him to vacate the land
and in 1988 the government decided to
carry out a series of raids there 34
members of the organization were
arrested for robber y rape and murder
among other crimes Abu bakir and his
followers felt that the government was
oppressing them and were not about to
accept it thus taking advantage of the
tremendous social unrest caused by the
crisis on the 27th of July 1990 112
islamist Rebels seized both the
Parliament and the offices of Trinidad
and Tobago television the country was
plunged into chaos and looting soon
began as a result 6 days and 24 deaths
later the rebels gave up and surrendered
with the government's promise to grant
them amnesty this Rebellion is to say
the only Islamic religious Insurgency
that the West has had since then
successful governments have adopted
austere reforms without much concern of
radical islamism however in recent years
it has become clear that this was a
mistake check it
out brutal ground for
[Music]
extremism over time countries forged
their own reputation and image in the
eyes of the rest of the world some
countries countes are known for
exporting a lot of oil such as Saudi
Arabia and Brazil While others are known
for leading the world economy such as
the United States and China in the case
of Trinidad and Tobago however his
reputation has been forged by news items
like these three accused a plotting
attack on New York's JFK Airport
arrested four people arrested in
Trinidad and Tobago over Carnival Terror
threat even so this news does not come
close to matching the most alarming fact
about Trinidad and Tobago which is that
it's the country with the highest rate
of jihadis s per capita in fact being a
country of barely 1,300,000 inhabitants
it's estimated that between 130 and 240
of its citizens joined daesh in Syria
and Iraq to give you an idea from the
United States about 250 joined dases
despite the fact that Uncle Sam's
population is almost
360 times that of this small Caribbean
nation and you may be wondering how on
Earth is this possible well very simple
first of all naturally because of the
finance ing of the global Jihad which
usually comes from Saudi Arabian donors
however the country's socioeconomic
circumstances also play an important
role in fact most of those who have
joined dases in Trinidad and Tobago meet
three very specific characteristics they
are men of African descent of about 35
years of age who have suffered
discrimination men who have come from a
context of poverty and people who have
often been in jail yet in Trinidad and
Tobago the recruitment of jihadists and
their expansion has been particularly
straightforward for one specific reason
the existence of a wellestablished
national network to give you an idea the
country's intelligence investigations
discovered that there was a recruitment
Network that extended throughout the
island of Trinidad at the center of this
network is this gentleman Imam nazim
Muhammad Muhammad has consistently
denied his relationship with dases yet
the data indicates
otherwise for example 70% of all
fighters in the country who joined dases
live near or within the religious
community over which Muhammad presides
and not only that some 15 members of his
family also join dases in Syria and Iraq
including his own daughter and
grandchildren on top of all that as if
it were not enough he is related to
emran Ali the husband of one of his
granddaughters and who was sanctioned in
2018 by the United States for financing
Isis so as you can see Trinidad and
Tobago seems to have become an
unexpected breeding ground for
international jihadism and I know what
you're wondering why this country well
you see the language of the trinidadians
is English an asset that served Dash to
increase its spread but also because
Dash is aware of the harsh living
conditions in the Caribbean Nations and
well if we consider that in Trinidad and
Tobago there is no law prohibiting
joining the caliphate and up until
brexit trinidadians could freely enter
the United Kingdom and from there the
rest of Europe one can understand the
attraction that the country has had for
Global Jihad with all this it's not
surprising that the United States has
begun to take an interest in this small
Caribbean nation in fact in in 2017
Trump already met with the then prime
minister of the country Keith Rowley at
the meeting they pledged to fight
against terrorism in the islands in a
reinforced Way by creating a new
surveillance system however analysts
warn of one thing the case of Trinidad
and Tobago may just be the tip of the
iceberg many predict a rise of jihadism
throughout South America but how true is
this well let's take a
[Music]
look a new problem in Latin
America
[Music]
those of you watching us or coming from
South America probably think of Guerilla
groups such as farc in Colombia or
shining path in Peru whenever the topic
of terrorism in the region comes up and
that's hardly surprising after all
jihadist terrorism in the region has
almost been always anecdotal in fact we
have to go back to the 1990s to find the
two major jihadist attacks in Latin
America that of the Israeli Embassy in
Buenos Ares in 1992 and that of the
association m Mutual israelita Argentina
the Amia in 1994 and do you know who is
responsible for these attacks an old
acquaintance hasbalah you see in 2006
the late prosecutor Alberto nisman and
his Deputy Marcelo Martinez abos
presented the report of their
investigation into the 1994 Amia bombing
the report directly accused the state of
Iran of being the main architect of the
attack and Hezbollah of having carried
it out however this would not be the
only occasion on which Iran and its
Lebanese Terror IST arm Hezbollah have
been active in Latin America ties with
Venezuela have also been repeatedly
highlighted through anti-American
rhetoric Iran has curried favor with
Venezuela in order to more easily
exploit the Region's Muslim communities
indeed the cartel of the Suns led by
Venezuelan Congressman doost Cabello and
the Lebanese cartel created by wiik mle
and which has close ties to Hezbollah
have repeatedly collaborated by sending
arms and narcotics to Damascus and tyan
Via flights on Venezuelan Airline
conviasa a practice known as Aero
terrorism yet despite the infamous role
that the Venezuelan dictatorship plays
in the entry of Hezbollah onto Latin
American territory the reality is that
this is not the main entry point for
jihadist terrorism into the region for
that we have to move further south to an
extreme hot spot for organized crime the
triple
border the triple border is the point
where the borders of Argentina Brazil
and Paraguay meet a point where
Corruption of Customs officials poor
border controls and money laundering is
the order of the day here organized
crime organizations from Latin America
and other parts of the world are
involved in drug trafficking human
trafficking and smuggling among other
crimes and who else do you think also
operates here indeed Hezbollah and not
just recently it's been doing so since
the 1980s as a result the free bordering
countries along with the United States
have carried out several security
initiatives at this particular Point
both to eliminate the presence of
organized crime and jihadist terrorism
but but so far these strategies have not
done much good and the reality is that
crime has intensified in this area and
can you guess which country is being hit
the hardest well none other than the
largest and most populated country in
Latin America
Brazil Brazil has been reporting the
presence of jihadist terrorists in its
territory for more than a decade in 2013
the country's federal police confirmed
the presence of seven jihadist groups in
national territory among them Hezbollah
Hamas and Kaa in fact in 2016 Brazil was
on the verge of being the victim of a
jihadist attack Brazilian police arrest
10 people suspected of planning
terrorist attacks for Rio de Janeiro
Olympics and in 2023 Brazilian
authorities have warned of the start of
a campaign within the country by taigi
jamaat a centuries old Islamic movement
founded in India that has been in the
crosshairs of world intelligence what's
more they have been linked in fact to
alqaeda and to the Madrid bombings of
2004 as as you can see for the moment
there have been no new jihadist attacks
in South America since those that
occurred in the 1990s in Argentina but
tension over the jihadist presence in
the region is on the rise Trinidad and
Tobago is the best example of this many
analysts now think that Latin America
could become a new epicenter for
jihadist recruitment but what do you
think do you think we will start to see
jihadist attacks in Latin America and
will the United States take any steps to
prevent the rest of the subcontinent
from following the same path as Trinidad
and Tobago you can leave us your answers
in the comments and as always if you
liked this video don't forget to like
And subscribe to our Channel and of
course hit the little bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news
coming soon once again thank you very
much for being there all the best and
see you next
time